aqui você fazer tanto tempo o público
escolheu o habitual e que quer falar
andar piso muito bem vindos à imagem
dele e hoje para a geek e fantasia
popular por botões trânsito strans
dimensionais até universo onde o setor
bater simples mas matematicamente
complexo porque envolve o universo
contas matemáticas e papel para
descobrir mais na nossa aula de mtb
odiei quando o lado bom da natureza que
hoje vai ser o desafio de sete obras do
papel eo que é que este motivo não bater
por martin db4 conseguem dobrar um papel
é sete meses não é site o desafio é para
sempre uma vez e por que estamos aqui
por fim da sétima vez desde 4 de final
fazer a dobra porque eu queria muito
duro e hoje vou tentar ultrapassar 7 mil
dobras para cima do edifício muito
passar a transmitir é muito difícil e
dizem também que nós dobraram uma folha
de papel uma única folha de papel 45
pesos altura vai ficar até a lua mas nós
vamos tentar dobrar oito vezes o papel
porque nós temos e que ajuda na nossa
mídia press
[Música]
138 tem um cálculo matemático que
escutaram expectativa para a inclusão
uma folha média de 0,2 em 2011 uma vez
que como todo mundo também 0,4 cêntimos
que quatro minutos depois vai se
desdobrar entre serviços é o dobro de
quatro e oito fácil se quiser um dos
dois vai fazer por 16 você vai sair
daqui dá muito pouco o registo e rápido
nos 45 vezes vai é a distância anda seu
planeta terra ea distância entre o
planeta ea lua coisas mais pequenas e
mais quatro álbuns aqui que é uma
ciência que não é exata portanto nós
vamos queimar a forma discreta pelo
colégio vai descobrir isso e não vai ser
a escolha do tamanho que é a folha a4 e
folha a3
as inscrições quanto maior for a folha
mais fácil é fazer a dobra e é por isso
que vou tentar que quando este
disposição para uma paralisação de uma
obra é a primeira a ficar muito bem a
folha com dobras terceira obra o as
obras acabam em grupo
esta é meu e podem ver meu não dá tá
muito duro e tentar lembrar aqui sétima
vez com qualquer um filme pode também
escolher vai realizar na época ela não
agüenta a opção que está fazendo que já
há muita opção vai tentar agora com a
folha a3 desconfiança
ok folha 46 vezes e agora vamos tentar
compor a crise
[Música]
uma obra e de você em casa qualquer um
de vocês vai fazer sete obras que ficam
aí nos comentários conseguiram
conseguiram as obras já conseguiram
fazer comenta e segunda bola sobra bateu
dobra agora podem ver é impossível fazer
a sétima obra
agora vamos tentar dobrar para 4 mas com
a ajuda da nossa preta com a opção de
continuar do banco então 4321 elp o foco
e vou tentar primeiro popular 3 por
supostamente ter pavor é maior portanto
vai ser mais fácil fazer a obra deve
bancar o express o primeiro não vou usar
a imprensa porque é muito fácil não é
bastou fazer 56 fundadora arrastar tudo
toda aí o pacote grande de ter muita
técnica
era só para isso uma obra está pronta
não faço não é uma rocha vulcânica por
países são muito bem organizados dando
mal e ninguém pode negar a minha máquina
preparei muito mais humano a fazer muita
força mas não só o papel em black de um
jantar em israel em cima de uma nova
fase agora é só passar muita opção já eu
vou soltar que vejam só faltava muito
apertado mesmo quase dobra gostosa
támbém um grosso aqui
esta nova aqui andamos a cop-16 qualquer
forma nota quarta obra e vamos agora
fazer a quinta a quinta obra está muito
difícil usar ó pessoal esta é nossa
quinta dobra o programa começa a fazer
aqui
isso eu vou tentar explicar conseguir
fazer a obra
[Música]
o funcionário do hotel ponte no rio a
capitol
vamos soltar a opção 3 214 a mais fina
na internet com uma folha mais finas
clube conseguir fazer os petrodólares
eu acho que alguns americanos conseguiu
fazer o pouso mas foi com papel
higiênico eu acho mas nós vamos tentar
aqui você cogita até o hospital porque é
o mais fino primeira obra a segunda obra
com poder para também mais fácil fazer
obras terceira dobra costa dobra eu acho
que já vou usar a imprensa
festas dobra o pessoal sétima obra só
com o dedo mas que já trouxe um pouco o
time sempre uma dobra em partes iguais
está em quarto e iguais ao convívio ea
técnica da obra de um só votar certo
desdobrado está muito pequeno principado
aquela que eu mais queria que a oitava
do oitavo posto no avaí em cima de uma
folha dobrada oito vezes vamos ver como
vai ficar
[Música]
é uma obra completa se não é uma obra
completa me parece está uma dobra 28
vezes na minha opinião eu acho que oito
contra mantém ou seja o caixão ficou 17
acham ficou 88 não conta porque assim
mas depois começa a bater na mesma tecla
já conquistaram a etapa do enduro mas
vem de produção e tem um projeto para
descontar a sair do papel prensa a
cortar um pouco vulgar povo que aconteça
aí um
[Música]
seu comportamento nas 11
então é isso aí eu não ficava o antigo
espírito vai fazer que não gostava como
tem embaixo que elas deixaram com 180
dólares 257 mil como entende já sabem
que 24 dos 32 feridos provavelmente
menos 1 bilhão e podem ver gráfico
enquanto o comentário lá e queria se
aproximar